hello everyone welcome to the biggest
ideas in the universe i'm your host sean
carroll
today is the q a video associated with
idea number seven which was quantum
mechanics
as you might imagine there were a lot of
questions about quantum mechanics but in
fact i'm going to try to keep
this particular q a video relatively
short and sweet because many of the
questions
will be things i address in later videos
there were a lot of questions about
the measurement process which i
intentionally explained was pretty
mysterious so it's a good thing to have
questions about
there's also questions that sort of
leapt ahead to issues of
uh quantum field theory in particular
which we will talk about that is one of
the greatest ideas one of the biggest
ideas in the universe
there is one question that kept coming
up that i think is worth addressing
right now because it really goes to the
heart of an
easy way to misunderstand quantum
mechanics which is
the appearance of discreteness you know
what i
what i mentioned in my explanation was
there was something called the wave
function
and this is sort of the fundamental
thing in quantum mechanics this is the
thing
psi of x that says what your
physical system is now one question by
the way is that sometimes i wrote psi of
x and other times i wrote psi of x
and t which one is it well it's the same
it's the same thing
psi is a function both of the
coordinates of whatever you're looking
at
and also of time so it's a function of x
and t
but at any one time we can just say what
is the wavefunction now at this time and
it would be
psi of x so it's perfectly okay to write
side of x even though it is a function
of both space and time
but the thing about the wavefunction is
that it's smooth right there's nothing
discrete or pixelated or latticized
about it
it's a function at every point there is
a value at every point in space there is
a value
and some people have heard either that
quantum mechanics
implies a discreteness of the universe
at some fundamental level
or that there is something called the
planck length
which gives some fundamental
discreteness to it when gravity comes
into the game
so first there is no fundamental
discreteness in quantum
mechanics okay discreteness can appear
because of certain special situations
this is what we encountered in let's say
the hydrogen atom
uh basically because we have if you
imagine
oops if you imagine this is x and we're
going to draw
the wave function in a hydrogen atom
there is some
nucleus here
which for a hydrogen atom is just proton
and then
there'll be some wave function and the
wave function has
you know there's a competition right you
want to look for the lowest energy
states of the electron
this is the wave function of an electron
in particular and
the electron doesn't have to be in its
lowest energy state but if it's not it
will generally radiate a photon and drop
down into its lowest energy state
so the first thing you want to look for
is the lowest energy state of
the electron and there's a competition
for the following reason
if the electron wave function becomes
very skinny then it has to change
rapidly and that rapid change of the
wave function
over space the sharpness of it costs
energy right the electron wave function
wants to be smooth and spread out
but it also wants to be near the nucleus
because it's an electromagnetic force
from the positively charged proton
pulling the electron toward the nucleus
so there's a competition and what you
get is
a wave function that looks sort of like
the gaussian the sort of bell curve that
we that we talked about
now it's not like i've seen that it's
not the wave function of an electron but
it's that's the general shape
and then we can have more uh complicated
wave functions where
it begins to look like this
for a higher excitation one and begins
to look like this
for the next excitation and things like
that there's a series of higher and
higher level
energies that the electron wave function
can be in
and the reason why is what we talked
about in the last video in the quantum
mechanics video
that it's kind of like a string that is
tied down
on both ends it's not tied down on both
ends the wave function
smoothly goes to zero gradually but it
eventually does go there and the point
is the wave function can't be non-zero
at infinity because it has to be
normalized to normalized as a way of
saying
that we know the probability of
measuring
the electron at some value x is given by
the absolute value of the wave function
for that
squared okay so the probability
has to add up to one the probability of
every possible outcome
so we would say in math in mathematic
terms is that the integral
of p of x dx so the area under the
probability curve for all values of x
has to equal one the probability of
finding it somewhere where you to look
has to equal one so that means that the
integral the area under the curve
of psi squared of x
dx equals one and if the wave function
just kept waving in arbitrarily large
ways
it would always have more and more
integral over it under it it would have
more
more
area under the wavefunction squared
curve so it has to die
out at infinity now having said that you
will soon find out that we cheat very
often in quantum mechanics
and we consider wave functions that are
not normalized in this way
but that's just for helpful reasons
along the way
and we can always fix it up by imagining
that we're cheating and
the real wave function dies off but
we're not paying attention to that
but when we care about the wave function
in an electron
then we have to send it to zero at
infinity and there you go
once you sent it to zero you get a
discrete set of solutions with definite
energies
that's where the discreteness comes from
in quantum mechanics the discreteness is
not built in
quantum mechanics is not a theory of
discrete stuff
quantum mechanics is a theory of smooth
stuff that sometimes appears discrete
because of boundary conditions for the
equations that we're solving and so
forth
now that's of course quantum mechanics
when we talk about these things
throughout
the whole series of videos well we we
say that something is true
we but we mean it within the context of
a certain theory we're trying to explain
right like when we say that
conditions at one moment in time
determine the future in the past
that might be true if we're talking in
the context of classical mechanics in
the laplacian paradigm
it might not be true in some other
theories okay so when i say that
wave functions are smooth i mean that in
quantum mechanics as it's understood
you can imagine trying to improve
quantum mechanics at least extend it
to include gravity okay so gravity
comes along with this idea of newton's
constant
newton's constant you saw oops
actually i should probably capitalize
newton right he was a
famous guy newton's constant of gravity
you saw it
in the gravitational force equation the
force due to gravity
is g times one mass times the other mass
over r squared the famous inverse square
law for gravity so that g is newton's
constant
when planck comes along and gives us h
the constant that is associated with
quantum mechanics
we now have three famous constants that
we can put to some good use right
three constants
we have g for gravity h bar
usually physicists these days like to
use h bar which is h over 2 pi
and of course the speed of light c and
one of the very first things
that max planck noticed when he invented
his constant
h we're now hbar is that you can take
dimensionally
you can take g newton's constant h
planck's constant and c the speed of
light and combine them to define
apparently fundamental looking
quantities like
length time energy mass
in a certain set of units called planck
units in particular the only one i'm
going to use
right now is the planck length
which is let's call it l sub p for
planck and it's
defined by the square root of h bar i've
written it down here so i can remember h
bar over g
divided by c cubed okay and
numerically it's approximately 1.6
times 10 to the minus 33 centimeters
so that's very tiny it's a very tiny
thing
planck's constant that's about punk's
length that is about
10 to the minus 20 times the radius of a
proton
so if you think the protons are small
the plot length is much much smaller
than that
now you may have heard people claim
that on distances approaching the plonk
length space time itself
is either non-existent or discrete comes
in little dots or whatever
well we have no idea what happens to
space time as like at
distances approaching the plonk length
we don't know we don't
sometimes we say we don't know but kind
of we do like in the sense that uh we
don't know we haven't proven that p
does not equal np uh but we kind of
suspect that it's true
we honestly don't know what's going on
with space time at the planck length
the reason to expect that something goes
on is
the formula for the planck length
involves
quantum mechanics gravity and relativity
okay h bar
g and c so there's this feeling
that once you quantize gravity and have
a true theory of everything including
the emergence of space-time itself
something will happen at the planck
length maybe
it's that space is discrete maybe space
doesn't exist as a useful concept
anymore
if you're a string theorist maybe the
planck's length is approximately the
size of a string it's not exactly
because there's other factors in there
but there's some relationship there okay
but the truth is we just don't know okay
and in fact
it's completely possible that time is
utterly smooth all the way down to the
plonk length or
sorry all the way down to zero that's
completely on the table as
one of the possibilities so it might be
true that there's some
fundamental discreteness at the planck
scale but we honestly don't know and
if it's true it's because of gravity
newton's constant appears in there it's
not
intrinsic to quantum mechanics itself
likewise with the planck
time you can define a unit of time
called the planck time
which is very very short very very fast
you might think that time is discrete on
intervals of the planck time
maybe maybe not actually most theories
of gravity
quantum gravity don't have time being
discrete to the long time at all
it might be true but we honestly don't
know so don't believe everything you're
told out there in popular physics land
maybe this is true but we have to be
honest about what we don't know
okay that was the sort of uh
rush out of the way clear the ground
question what i really wanted to do is
take advantage of this q a video
to discuss something that honestly i
should have discussed in the regular
video but it was getting a little long
in the tooth so
i cut it short i want to go into you
know we go from the wave function
psi of x and we get from that a
probability distribution
for observing the electron or whatever
particle at different values of x
given by psi squared i should be careful
and write its psi
of x squared and this is the bourne rule
right this is the probability rule
invented by max born
schrodinger invented his wave function
hoping that it would be something
physical and measurable it was born who
gave you this probability
interpretation and said actually it's a
probability you're going to make a
certain measurement
and that is what we still use today so
you might think it's very very natural
to think that
the wave function is not real it's just
a tool
right we we've had before we ever got to
quantum mechanics we had the notion of a
probability distribution
in statistical mechanics which was set
up in the 19th century in the 1800s
people like boltzmann and maxwell had
this idea that if you have a box of gas
like the air in this room you don't know
where every single atom or molecule is
you don't know how fast it's moving
but you can have a probability
distribution that says what is the
probability that a certain atom
or a certain molecule will have a
certain location and a certain momentum
okay
the distribution function it's sometimes
called but that is
purely an expression of your ignorance
boltzmann and maxwell didn't think that
there was no such thing as the location
and velocity of all the different
particles
they just admitted they didn't know them
so when you see something
like the born rule like this probability
distribution in quantum mechanics
of course your first guess is going to
be that somehow quantum mechanics is
about our ignorance of the real
situation
going on okay i don't think that's true
in fact most people don't think that's
true there's some plucky holdouts who
think that that is what it's about
if that's what it's about it's way more
subtle than just saying the electron has
a location
x but we don't know where it is okay and
so that's what i wanted to get into what
is the reason why
we don't just treat the weight function
psi
as a tool for figuring out a probability
distribution why do we
why are we tempted at least to attribute
some reality to it
i keep having to use these weasel words
because physicists don't agree
about what quantum mechanics actually
says so i have my opinions about what
the right way to talk is
but i can't talk that way yet in the
next video we'll go into a little bit
about the different
foundational theories of quantum
mechanics and then you can draw your own
judgments
but so to get here i need to talk about
the fact that quantum mechanical wave
functions can
interfere with each other this is just
one of the most absolutely important
features of quantum mechanics
interference
this is what separates wave functions
from classical probability distributions
okay
and there is a nice way to talk about it
the very very famous
double slit experiment so that's what
we're going to talk about
you know when i wrote my uh book
something deeply hidden
i i tried i had an aspiration to like
not use all of the same explanations and
thought experiments and illustrations
and examples that everyone else uses
so the two that i really didn't want to
use were schroedinger's cat
and the double slit experiment and guess
what i used both of them
because you think about it and they're
both really good they both really
explain
something that is very very important so
why not we'll talk about the double slit
experiment
also you know that it's nice to be novel
and try to do something a different way
but people are not blank slates people
do not read your book with
zero knowledge of the stuff you're
talking about
so it is also important to make sure
that people understand what you're
saying
in the context of what they've already
heard elsewhere so people have heard
about the double slit experiment
therefore it's important to talk about
one thing to emphasize about the double
slit experiment is that
it was not like one of the foundational
inspirational experiments that drove us
to quantum mechanics
the double slit experiment was talked
about and we knew what it would do
long before we ever did it i know that
feynman uh popularized the double slit
experiment in the feynman lectures on
physics i'm not sure if he was the first
to say everything we're going to say
about it there was a classical version
of the double slit experiment by thomas
young years before but the quantum
mechanical one
has important wrinkles i think it's
eventually been done these days we've
done the double set experiment but it's
very hard to do
for reasons that we'll explain so here's
the experiment you have some source
which shoots out electrons let's say
okay
and out of it comes electrons and you
know we don't know exactly the direction
they're going in it's not like a laser
that is perfectly collimated
and then we have let's see if i can
[Music]
make this a bit more impressive we have
two slits
okay so we have a barrier
that has two slits in it like that and
then on the other side
we have a detector that can actually
you know flash when an electron hits it
so
here are this is the uh
barrier i guess we called it
with two slits
that the electrons can pass through and
here's the detector screen
and what would happen so we're going to
go through different examples of what
you might guess
happens okay so in this kind of setup
um so how can i do that let me see if i
can actually just
do this so what i'm going to do is
copy this duplicate
good i'm going to go through different
possibilities okay
so what if you send waves through the
slits
so instead of sending particles what if
it you just like
submersed the whole thing in water and
literally like pounded on the water so
that a wave
passed through and waves you know
propagate
outward in wave fronts like that
and uh that's a little sloppy i can do
better than that let's like not let it
hit
and what happens is when the waves hit
the slits they sort of
if they hit the barrier they just stop
if they hit the slits they go on through
the slits but they
separately propagate outward from each
slit so what you get is
uh circular waves coming out of this
slit
and then another set of circular waves
coming out of this slit
okay so when you hit the detector let's
say that in this case what the detector
detects
is the height of the wave hitting the
detector
so there will be places like right here
where you get constructive interference
i hope you can read that constructive
interference in other words the two
waves one coming out of one slit one
coming out of the other one
go up and they go up in the same place
so they actually add
together but then you might get another
place where
one wave is up but the other wave is
down actually that's probably
not there let's say that that is uh
here okay this is at the crest of one
wave but the trough of another wave
and there you would get destructive
interference so they would cancel out
right because a wave can either go up or
go down and you add a positive number to
a negative number and they cancel out
so what you see over here isn't what we
call an interference pattern you would
see
sort of a lot of tall waves
right in the middle and then they would
there be a place where they almost
canceled out and then another
peak where they generally constructively
interfere and then they would cancel out
and so forth
so you'd get this kind of pattern of
waves coming together
and interfering with each other that's
the wave situation
okay what about if we just send out
particles
i'm not going to redraw it let me just
do particles here
if we just send particles through and
that they all already look like
particles on the diagram so that's good
then basically if the particles hit the
barrier they just stop
if they go through the slits then they
would just continue on with whatever
momentum they had
and the pattern you would see of dots of
particles on the detector screen
would look more less like this there'd
be
two big peaks where the two slits
had particles going through them okay so
that's the expectation before we do
anything quantum mechanical we talked
about classical particles classical
waves
classical particles you go through the
slit and you hit the other side
there's no interference or anything like
that classical waves you go through both
slits
at the same time and therefore there can
be interference and that is in fact what
you see this is what young did
with light this is one of the
demonstrations that light has a
wavelength character that light goes up
and down okay there's there are
interference patterns
so what happens when you do electrons
quantum electrons
so again i'm not going to try to cut and
paste there's a source
there is the barrier
and then there is the detector
once again and you can ask the question
quantum mechanically what should happen
this is very difficult to actually do
the experiment because
electrons are tiny little things uh
they're even if they're wave functions
those wave functions generally have tiny
little wavelengths and so
in order to notice the waveness of it
you want the whole shebang including the
distance between the slits
to be not that much bigger than the
wavelength of an electron
that is a hard thing to arrange quantum
mechanically and experimentally but
you can do it people are very very good
at this so what do you see when you turn
on electrons
well of course we know that at the
detector screen
oops that's a thick one and here's the
here are the slits we know that if we
have a good detector
one of the things quantum mechanics says
is that in fact
we see individual dots at the detector
okay so it's not
exactly like the classical waves where
you really had a wave going up and down
at the detector
you see dots so maybe you see a dot
there i'll make the dots a little bit
bigger
so that they can uh be seen yeah there's
a dot
and then you see that there's you know
you collect over time you send electrons
from the gun
they go through the slits you get some
accumulation of electrons
and what you have is what would you
actually
see
if we add them all up
is something that looks like this so
something that looks like
the interference pattern we see a
collection of many electrons hitting the
screen but the collection of all of them
over time
does not look particle-like okay if the
electrons were particles you would see
two big concentrations of dots but that
is not what you see you see
many little concentrations with a big
peak in the middle
and then fringes in an interference
pattern a very clear interference
pattern
so that shouldn't surprise you right now
right because you've been trained in
quantum mechanics and you know that what
passes
through the slits is not a particle-like
electron but the wave function
of the electron so in the wave function
behavior
it is very wave-like not surprisingly
right
so you're going to get these
interference patterns because
the electron doesn't choose to go
through one slit or another
the wave function of the electron goes
through both slits
and this is important because this is
one of the reasons there's other reasons
but this is one of the reasons why
you can't just think of quantum
mechanics as a theory of probability
distributions
because if you said well the electron
has a location
we just don't know where it is then it
would still be
true that when you do an experiment like
this the electron would go
through one slit or the other but
this behavior of the waves going through
both slits and then
interfering is what is actually seen and
that is fundamentally different
than what you would get if you had
particles okay so the waviness of the
electron when it's not being observed
is fundamentally important and you know
just to make sure
you understand the thought experiment
set up here
the electron is being observed here
or measured if you like
the wave function of the electron does
not collapse when it goes through
the slits okay it goes through
undisturbed it does not become entangled
with the slits it does not get measured
by the slits nothing like that
now you might want to ask well why is
that true very good question another
reason why
doing the experiment very carefully is
hard but you can do it
you just don't want the wave function of
the electron to get entangled
with the slits or anything else in
between the source and the detector
so that should make you convinced that
you can't just
replace the wave function by some
classical probability
distribution the wave function
interferes with itself
that means that the wave function
somehow has something like reality
to it otherwise how could it interfere
with itself classical probability
distributions don't interfere with
themselves number one
they're never negative so they literally
can't interfere with themselves
but also classical probability
distributions are expressions of
our ignorance an expression of our
ignorance cannot interfere with itself
right but a physical wave can interfere
with
itself so from experiments like this it
seems like classic that the wave
function is
real not everyone agrees that that's
true there are certainly
versions of quantum mechanics where the
wave function is not real
but you need to work very hard let's put
it that way to make something where you
have a wave function
but it's not real okay now of course
this is not the end
of the story this is this is not quite
the fun part of the
double slit experiment so let's do
quantum electrons again
going through the slits
but now we're going to monitor
which slit they go through so you say to
yourself well
i'm still disturbed by this idea that
the wave function is going through both
slits
so i will set up a little spy to see
which slit the electron goes through
it's not hard to imagine doing in
thought experiment lane this is trivial
to do right the electron
is an electrically charged particle just
put little snoopers by each of the slits
that will notice the electric field of
the electron as it passes by
and then you know then you know which
one it passes through okay
so what happens when you do that
slits
detector
over here well we've said that when the
electrons leave the source
they're a quantum wave function but now
we're spying on them so we have
let's say a little eyeball astronomers
draw
observers as little eyeballs that's not
my best eyeball ever i can do better
there we go so the eyeball looking to
see
is the electron going through that slit
or through that slit okay
so it's not really an eyeball it's some
detector of electrons but it's the same
general idea
what do you get at the detector
when you notice so you can do this i
mean you can have a little detector that
goes ping
it went through the left slit thing it
went through the right slit that's very
easy to do
very easy to set up and here's what you
get
you get some electrons you detected make
them bigger than that
right okay good
thing
what do you get if you if you can sort
of see it in my impressionistic
drawing here is
not an interference pattern like that
not a wave like that but you get two big
peaks
as if particles have gone through the
two detectors
so it depends on where you are and how
comfortable you've become with quantum
mechanics but in some sense that
shouldn't surprise you either
remember the motto of quantum mechanics
is that what the thing
is the electron or any other quantum
system is a wave
but what it looks like is a particle
when you observe it
and how you change the experiment in
this case was you looked at it
you looked to see which slit it went
through so in the copenhagen or textbook
way of talking about this
what you would say is i observed the
electron
which slit it went through i will never
see it go through two slits
at once that is not something that
quantum mechanics allows me to do i will
see it either as a particle going
through one
slit or as a particle going through the
other slit and therefore when it
eventually hits the screen
it will have behaved like a particle
because i measured it and made it into a
particle okay
now there's a different story you would
tell in many worlds or other
interpretations of quantum mechanics but
they all agree
on what the prediction here is for um
what you see in this experiment and this
is what has been done
so it's just driving home uh
the lesson which you which you should
have learned already that the wave
function represents something real or at
least
seems to unless you work very hard to
avoid it and
the role of measurement is absolutely
crucial in quantum mechanics
what we will try to get to in the next
lecture are ways to make measurements
seem less spooky less mysterious less
weird
um but we don't agree right so physics i
i think i know what's going on when you
measure something because i'm a fan of
many worlds but other people are fans of
other ideas and they have different
ideas of what a measurement
really is uh there are people out there
who think that measurements really
require a conscious human observer okay
there's they're very very tiny minority
of such people but they really do exist
i don't you know so just so we're clear
just so i'm not
hiding anything from you even though we
use the word
measurement or observer or whatever
that's just a relic of how we invented
this stuff in the 1920s okay it's not
necessary the in most
versions of quantum mechanics that
people take seriously today
not just many worlds but many other ones
we have absolutely rigorous
physics-based explanations for what a
measurement
is that have nothing to do with
consciousness
or agents or human perceptions or
anything like that
what it has to do in most versions of
quantum mechanics
is decoherence is the system that you're
observing becoming entanglement with its
wider
environment so we'll have to talk about
that later but uh
in the next video in fact but this is
the experiment this is the empirical
reality that we have to match so if you
want to have a new
version of quantum mechanics of your own
if you don't like many worlds or any of
the other alternatives on the market
this is an experiment you have to take
absolutely seriously
okay i only wanted to say one more thing
i know i said i was going to try to keep
it short so
um and the one more thing is one of
these it's one of these questions that i
have difficulty
answering i'm not exactly sure what
would count as an answer but the
question that got
asked several times is
what is the wave function
or in other words sometimes it's
phrased as what is waving
if you have a wave function um
you know i think that the right answer
is
the wave function is the thing that the
universe is you know the way fun there's
there's
the the best way it might not be the
most um
satisfying way but the best way to say
it is there's something called reality
something called the universe or the
cosmos or whatever you want to call it
and we have been searching since the
beginning of physics for
a representation of that reality in the
language of mathematics or some other
analogous representation and the way
that quantum mechanics
represents reality is through the wave
function okay
that's what it is so there isn't any
thing that is waving that is somehow
more fundamental
than the wave function so if you have
water and you have a wave on the water
then yes you can say look there are
water molecules and there's a collection
of them and they make a fluid and it is
waving
okay if you have the electric and
magnetic fields well then you have an
electric field
and you have a magnetic field and those
are fields that are defined at different
points in space and time and they're
waving they're going up and down
the wave function is reality it is not
there's no deeper level
it's not made of wave functiony stuff
it's not made of
uh monads or something like that it is
the the essence of the world
now we can be more mathematically
rigorous about it
we can say that psy is an
element of what is called hilbert space
but this is going to be singularly
unhelpful
if you want to know what's waving
hilbert space is a vector space okay
it's a it's a vector space which means
that the elements of hilbert's base are
vectors
you can add them together you can scale
them it is a
complex vector space
and there's some other is so complex
just means that the values of the
vectors the components of the vectors
are complex numbers
when you scale the vectors you can scale
them by complex numbers
so in other words this is just for the
math geeks out there
if psi 1
and psi 2 are both elements of hilbert
space
then alpha
times psi one plus beta
times psi two is an element of hilbert's
base
so if you take two wave functions
they're vectors
you can add them together you can scale
them by complex numbers
there's a couple other of technical
restrictions on the kinds of vector
spaces that are hilbert's faces complete
vector spaces they're normed vector
spaces which means you can take dot
products in them
but that's what it is it's a vector
space and
you might say well that's a little bit
confusing because
i get that if i think of these as
functions a wave function
i get that i can add functions together
that makes sense but why should i think
of as a function as a vector
so i think of vectors right so sorry let
me be clear
the word space here is not being used in
the sense of the three-dimensional space
we lived we talked earlier about the
fact that mathematicians
use the word space to mean any set of
things which has some extra structure so
hilbert's space is a vector space
meaning it is a set of things and the
extra structure it has is it's a vector
space you can add things together you
can scale them by real numbers
there is a zero vector there's a zero
element of hilbert space
okay so it's a space what does it mean
to say it's a vector space well this is
what it means to say it's a vector space
you can add and scale but
what does this have to do with our usual
notion of vectors right like when we
have vectors we think of having a plane
like
x y and then there's a little line with
an arrow
and then maybe there's another line
maybe i'll make a different color right
another line with another arrow
and then i can add them together by sort
of shifting the yellow arrow over here
and that gets me the resultant
vector like this so if this is
vector v and this is vector
w then this is vector
v plus w
so that's pictures like this you might
have seen before okay
make it bigger there you go vectors
arrows
with lengths and directions and you can
add them together but
functions seem like something very
different this is a two dimensional
vector
a function isn't you know to describe a
function requires not just
two pieces of information but basically
an infinite number of pieces of
information right a function
if i have x and here's my wave function
psi of x
at every point there is a value
right if this is the single point x star
then this value here is
psi at x star
and in particular in principle to
specify the whole wave function means
that at an infinite number of points
x i have to give you a complex number
psi of x
okay well as i think hopefully you're
i'm hinting
i'm uh being suggestive enough to
let you in on what's going on here this
is
a two-dimensional
vector space
remember we talk about dimensionality
right up down left right forward
backward i can take
two things and put them together at 90
degrees a third thing but not more than
that in space
in a plane i can take two directions and
put them perpendicularly
in other words i can separately specify
the x component and the y component of
these vectors
so let me explain what that means
and make that a little bit more explicit
move this down there we go
so in this two-dimensional vector space
just redraw the x y
if i have a vector
there's a vector v i can
drop down perpendicular lines to each of
the axes
and this is v in the x direction the
component of v
in the x direction and this is the
component of v
in the y direction and sometimes you
will see v
written as v x times a unit vector
in the x direction x hat plus v
y plus a unit vector in the y direction
okay
so you need to give me two numbers to
express a two dimensional vector
what i'm saying over here for the wave
function is
you need to give me an infinite number
of numbers to express a function
an infinite number of complex numbers
but the difference between complex and
real doesn't matter here
so it turns out that that's fine what we
have here is
an infinite dimensional vector space
and you can think of expressing that
vector so you have
psi of x
forget the vector sign on x that just
makes things redundant and complicated
um just the one-dimensional line that
the electron is moving on
we expressed the two-dimensional vector
as a set of components times unit
vectors
we can do that for this function here
also this would be
a sum over x of
the value of psi at the point x
times a unit vector
i'm not even sure how to write this i
will i will do it paul directed and
write it like this
okay so this little notation means
unit vector not unit vector it's not
really unifector sorry
it's a basis vector
at x and what this means is
at this x star right here i construct a
delta function a delta function was this
is all paul dirac who invented all this
stuff right the
uh very famous british um quantum
mechanic
he said look i can think of a function
as
the collection of what the function does
at x equals 0 what it does at the next
point x the next point x the next point
x there's a literally infinite number of
points x
if i tell you what the function does at
every one of those values of x i've told
you the function
i want to think of that function as a
set of
unit vec not i keep saying unit vectors
basis vectors
they turn out not to be unit vectors
because they're not normalizable in any
easy way this is why quantum mechanics
is hard mathematically this is why
infinite dimensional vector spaces are
hard
but the point is you have a function
that serves as a basis function
which is zero everywhere except at one
point where it's infinite
we call this the dirac delta function
i realize i'm getting much more into the
weeds here that i was planning on
getting when i started this video but
the direct delta function
by the i figure by the end of the q a
videos it's really the hardcore audience
that's listening here right so you you
want to hear this stuff
so i have delta of x
minus x star
this is equal to zero
at x not equal to x star
and it equals infinity at x equals x
star
now because you're hardcore and serious
at least half of you
are just fainting with the how appalled
you are
that i am saying this if i were to plot
the direct delta function
so here is x and here is delta of
x minus x star and here is the value
x star then indeed
the direct delta function looks like
this 0
zero zero zero boom infinity
it goes all the way up and then it's
zero zero zero zero okay
but infinity is not a number you can't
just say
the function equals infinity if a
serious mathematical
person you're you're just appalled at
how sloppy this is being
what you mean i know how to do it right
don't worry you
have to do it right is the following
what do you mean by
the function delta of x minus x star
you mean that if you take an integral
from minus infinity to infinity
of any function f of x
times delta of x minus x star
dx well what is that going to be so you
have some other function
f
here's f of x
this construction where you integrate
f of x times delta gives you zero
everywhere
except that x star and then it gives you
the value of f of x
this gives you f at x star
and you might say well why doesn't it
give you infinity because you multiply
the infinite delta function by
uh the finite value of f but it's also
infinitesimally thin
right there's no thickness there and
you're asking for the thickness the
total area under a curve
so this is literally the the sleight of
hand that is being pulled here
is that in the sloppy sense you're
taking 0 times infinity and getting a
finite number
you don't have to do that i'm just doing
it for educational pedagogical purposes
this expression is the definition
of delta of x minus x star it is a
distribution
not a function when you integrate it
against a function you get the value of
that function at a point
anyway the point of all this is that
direct delta functions can be used to
make
these basis vectors at different values
of
the different values of x different
values of location in space
and then rather than thinking of the
function as a curve one value for every
location of x
you can think of the function as a
vector and in fact what you would do is
to be really really uh
[Music]
precise about it you would say this is
not
the usual function that we draw this is
the vector
psi and this is dirac's bra cat
notations this is a ket
vector psi this is an element of the
hilbert space
okay now all i'm trying to do here
is dazzle you with math and science so
that you stop asking what is waving
when we talk about the wave functions
remember this is the motivational
question here what
is psi so as far as the math goes or
even as far as the physics goes
there's no problem telling you exactly
what psy
does okay there's also no problem
understanding what psi
represents it represents reality in this
quantum mechanical viewpoint which may
or may not be true
but that's what it represents we think
that whatever reality is
it is represented it acts as if it is a
vector which is an element of a hilbert
space
we don't even know if the hilbert space
of the universe
really is infinite dimensional or not
that's a question for another day
but uh it's certainly a very very large
number of dimensions
so at some point these questions about
like
what is it really what is it made of
what is it doing the waving these
questions stop having answers you bottom
out
you're at the point where you just say
no this is reality this is the most
fundamental level there's no
place deeper than this to go in some
sense it's it's
uh i mean i'm sure there is some
mystical tradition in which
uh this kind of thing is commonplace the
universe is the universe
and you're not allowed to ask further
questions about it
um wittgenstein says that thereof we
cannot speak we must remain silent right
the mystical is what he said is the
thing that we can't speak about
maybe he meant the wave function of the
universe i don't know but the point is
there isn't any simple answer in
familiar everyday terms to the question
what is waving or what is the wave
function made of the wave function
is an element of hilbert's space it is a
vector space a very large dimension and
that's what it is that's the best we can
say
at least right now maybe someday we'll
be able to say even more
i think that's all i got for um
questions
today so we have a good new video coming
out next i'll see you then